[Music]
all right there's this
woman who has this 30 year old woman
who has led her whole life like a normal
life
um and recently she went to the doctor
because she was experiencing
severe abdominal pain and she
found out that she's actually suffering
from testicular cancer she got balls
yeah like inside of her still yes um so
she's the only girl that really knows
what it feels like to get kicked in the
nuts
right if she got kicked there yeah i
mean she got cancer of it so she knows
what it kind of feels like
what's the right word you can't say
hermaphrodite anymore right but
what's the scientific word well so she
got diagnosed with
androgen in insensitivity
syndrome which is a condition where a
person is genetically
male but has all the physical traits of
a woman
so she has been married for the last
nine years intersex that's the word
and with her uh husband like there were
there was a time where they were
trying to have kids for a long time and
like nothing was happening because of
the fact that she just doesn't have a
uterus
oh wait so she has a vagina but it's she
has a vagina she has testes on the
inside yes
instead of ovary didn't her gyno
see that she didn't have a uterus
apparently she just found out at the age
of 30 that she's genetically a man
huh where is this at so this takes place
in india
and the crazy thing is that her sister
also her 28 year old sister is her
brother
technically because she also has the
same condition and
two of her aunts have the same condition
so it's hereditary yes it's hereditary
oh
what if the grandpa was like my family
is all
females and he dies and he's like oh i'm
so sad
he's gonna tell you well i don't know
but he but but now he
finds out he actually had all the boys
he wanted but he's dead so you can't
like
okay yeah so that's true yeah so
it's really crazy because they're saying
like from her entire appearance like
even her voice her she's developed
breasts
she has normal external genitalia
everything
that's kind of a guy's dream come true
if you don't want
kids you could she doesn't even have to
take birth control you could just come
in her all day
wait so i mean pre-cum um
with her situation when she found out is
that when her
the rest of her family found out as well
about themselves
oh uh or like did like this
no yeah you know what i'm saying like
there's these two aunts that
never had kids either what the hell is
going on you know what i'm saying well
apparently the aunt's head had this
revelation a long time ago or like it's
it they assume
or i'm assuming based off how they're
writing this article that they had
already known
and i don't know when the sister found
out i just know about this 30 year old
that currently just found out out of the
blue
yeah and yeah and like
so she's saying that like uh uterus and
ovaries have been absent since
birth she has never experienced
menstruation
and that's like a girl's dream come true
right well not if you want to have kids
well i mean what if you could have kids
and then you don't have to do the period
part though
and you got a million dollar head start
i'll take it that's the best you're
right but yeah so she has a blind vagina
it's blind i mean that's what i was
calling it
for dick i know
but yeah so then when when
[Laughter]
but yeah so then they said that when
they looked at her chromosome
their chromosomes it's actually an x y
and not an x
x wow so x y is for male x x is p
that's freaking crazy yeah so
and it's even crazier that now she knows
she has
cancer too on top of it because it's a
singular oh [ __ ]
so can she just remove her balls then
because
i mean it's not like they're on the
outside like
can she just have it removed or does
that damage something else or is her
husband going to donate his balls to him
because they don't need he doesn't
really need it also
is he going to have a moment where he's
like am i gay
i don't know what was the husband's
reaction oh my goodness
yeah like where is
[Laughter]
did she come because like if she has
balls doesn't it have semen in there oh
does she probably came normally like a
girl
did she shoot ropes so her husband
probably was like damn my girl's a
squirter like crazy
or like he always thinks that he's
busting in and then it's just
falling out yeah
it's a different color why is this milky
substance swirling
he's busting a big globe like you know
how you guys can move your dick and
stuff like it like i wonder if she could
do that inside
it's kegels though well there's a
difference between we're talking about
ball stacks versus like a shaft
yeah i'm talking about the shaft now i
don't know i think she's got a shaft no
but the
vagina the cervix is technically an
inverted penis okay
but anatomically yeah but so maybe she
can move her cervix
i think she only has balls right because
everything else she's
yeah she's still a yeah she has a vagina
and an operating one
yeah so i'm i'm thinking it's like what
bart just said like anatomically yeah
maybe
vaginal canal is like like an inside out
penis does she have a vas deferens i
don't know what does that mean
it's the connect stuff that makes not a
friend's ferdinand
[Music]
yeah then she could shoot that nut out
well they did mention that
because of the fact that her testicles
are immature
like that's the reason why the estrogen
they never dropped they didn't get
making fart jokes
this is so immature
yeah so that's the reason why the
estrogen in her body took over more than
the testosterone because there was so
little of it
and that's why she didn't like fully
have the appearance of
a male yeah okay because if she still
had her balls i'm like
why did it never go into gear it's like
well you know how
like how far in there are they cause
like you know when boys balls drop
did she had like i wonder if she had
some like balls they're just
more inside her body maybe she's really
cold all the time
no maybe it was because like her ever
since birth like before she was even
born like she just already had like a
vagina
yeah because her exterior is all female
yeah
so are the balls like inside i mean
that's what they say about
our ovaries they technically are like
balls yeah they're testicles but they
turn into ovaries
so she probably has balls but she
doesn't have ball sacks like a dude
because she has a vagina
so she her balls are probably just
inside maybe a sack is in there too
i don't know maybe i wonder if it's like
an amazon package
is it like up here like where the ori
should be like it's up
up up in the ovary that far up it's
right right here but then it's balls
for her yeah that seems like a really
spread out ball
do you think if you rub her over right
ovaries are like really far apart do you
think if she rubs her ovaries she's like
[ __ ] yeah
no because i could rub my ovary and i
don't feel like she has balls though
when people rub your balls are you like
[ __ ] yeah oh just if someone's like
sometimes i'm more like
i always think of the chinese medicine
ball
it's medicine balls you know yeah can
you imagine being the doctor that has to
break this news to the couple
cause like the couple's been hurting and
he's like look at that x-ray
uh first of all um your wife's not
who you think she is yeah who is he even
talking to first i know obviously the
patient oh really obviously obviously
i walk into a room i look at you guys i
realize you got girl
like balls i'm the doctor i'm like can i
talk to you first
you need your medical license revoked oh
[ __ ]
she's still the same person she was just
this one anatomical feature
exactly so it's a mind-blowing feature
it's mind-blowing if i went to the
doctor and they go you're a female i'm
like
whoa like i need to sit down like if i'm
standing up i hope the doctor goes you
sit down for a second because
this is going to be different it's not
like oh [ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] yeah so they're saying now
[Laughter]
that they're being cancelled they're
counseling the patient and her husband
and they're advising them to continue
living life as they have
let me do something
i wonder if it is that surprising though
if she had it in her family already like
she's already at least
heard about it i wonder i mean it is
surprising
that would be funny if she knew all her
ants had it and she goes no
or maybe the doctor should bring the
ants in to tell her that would be
someone else oh yeah
that's true like it's an intervention
yeah
sit down we need to tell you something
all the women in this family think about
how my blood is
imagine that i don't know how you you
made babies but you also have them
that is crazy but imagine like the next
time they have to have sex right
like no matter what even as a husband no
matter how much you love
your wife there's gotta be just that
moment
you know when you're about to get in
there i know do you think you could do
it
i don't i mean of course you're gonna do
it i'm already in love you guys are so
homophobic you have like an imagination
so your brain just
like thinks of interesting things that
next time you have to get in there you
know i'm like
that you're touching her balls yeah i'm
like kind of like when when you fall in
love with or like you hear these stories
when you fall in love like this couple
they fall in love
and then later on down the line they
realize oh [ __ ] you're my brother it's
like
it's just same thing for me
yeah you gotta consider okay so you
can't well brother's a little bit
different
obviously that's some jon snow [ __ ] i'm
saying it's the same thing i'm just
saying like the glass shattering is
similar yeah you got to consider the
fact that your wife is
kind of a man that's one thing but not
really
she's sick with cancer she's exactly the
same you're not gonna be able to have a
hasn't that's baby nine years it's
different right like the same woman she
was
it's just she has balls inside her
that's it so for you and steve you
wouldn't care like steve's a woman
i don't care he looks exactly he looks
exactly the same
everything that attracted me to him is
still there everything's the same
but we found out that inside him that
somewhere i can't even see
you have a uterus he has a uterus but
what if that's just like inception
what if it's like inception where it's
like now that she knows
things begin to actualize because it's
like when you suppress some [ __ ]
but now that she knows something starts
growing some chicks
her voice starts to get a little lower
they remove the cancer and suddenly
she's healthy down there and things
happen
she gets a fade she grows a mullet
starts wearing coach glasses
this one event changed her whole life i
know right yeah i really wonder if
if it if the treatment would be to
remove the testicles like what would
happen
yeah it would because it seems like
that's the
place that's holding her this is hot
yeah that's the next question do you
want to remove your balls or do you want
to add a shaft
right true i mean you got to be fair
like she's she gets them removed and she
stops working on cars she's like
oh my favorite hobbies
i just really want to get into like
cookies that's true
i wouldn't mind i still keep [ __ ]
that [ __ ] because it's like it still
feels the same it's not like a change
yeah and it's the same thing as like if
the doctor found a rice krispie treat or
something in her
liver that's how i feel and i'm like cut
it out yeah
get it out of there get there yeah put
it in the wrapper i'll eat it
now i'm looking at rice krispie treats
just with balls in them it's like
literally right there
i was like it's just a thing you just
gotta cut it out
[Music]
so
you